okay so She-Hulk episode 3 has just
dropped on Disney plus and throughout
this video we're gonna be going over
what happens the Easter eggs in it and
also how the Abomination plot might tie
with the Thunderbolts smash that Thumbs
Up Button like you're The Wrecking Crew
and don't forget to subscribe for our
breakdowns on the show every week
without the way let's not waste any more
of your time let's get into the
breakdown of the Wong Cinematic Universe
[Music]
now when she's not twerking she's
working on the Abomination case after
last week's reveal that he'd been
sneaking out to participate in clubs
that we don't talk about we see the
other side of this with him eventually
getting freed we initially open with the
damage controlled super max prison
that's based on the cube in the comics
whereas last week Jen was sheepishly
moving through the compound now she's
flashing her badge and storming through
the lasers she's that Blonsky lied to
her but it was it was just all semantics
you said to my face that you never
turned into the Abomination anymore no I
said I choose not to you know these were
extenuating circumstances now there's
two QR codes in this episode with the
first being on Emil's prison uniform and
the second being later on Pug's laptop
whilst the latter one scans to give you
some free She-Hulk Comics the one on the
uniform unfortunately doesn't work on my
phone but we've left it on screen right
now so if your kids can manage to grab
it then write it in the comments below
now I love how we can see in Excel that
he has a singing bowl set and typically
these are used to create a relaxing
sound to just chill you out he says he
was forced by Wong to go to the fight
club sorry the the club and this episode
features a lot of appearances by the
character now in the comics it was
Doctor Strange who ended up going to the
law firm and we had quite a different
storyline with him issue 3 send it
around the murder of Bailey Briggs who
came back as a ghost with the help of
strange he'd return to this Mortal Kyle
to reveal who had killed him and there
was a big discussion early on about
whether a ghost could testify or not
they actually brought up the snap and
said that because people had gone and
then come back that the same rules
should apply with ghosts too he blamed
his wife for it so that his true killer
could get off scott free and go to hell
forever he tried to kill Jen to cover
this up and he ended up being stuck in
prison for his entire 100 plus years
sentence due to this attempted murder
now in the comic strange was the
sorcerer supreme or as here it's Wong we
even get a sort of LinkedIn profile for
the character listing all of his jobs
including that when he was a librarian I
committage and also when he worked there
as a Target sales associate spent about
10 minutes weighing up whether he worked
at a Target as a sales associate but
with a location being committosh I think
he just did it with the Wizards now
Bruce Banner is a mutual connection and
the pair of course met at the start of
infinity war from here we get Jen
breaking the fourth wall and what I
think is the best one so far I love how
she just takes her hands off the wheels
and you can see everything continuing to
move in the background clearly showing
it's a background I know you can't wait
to see Wong I get it I just want to make
sure that you don't think this is one of
those Cameo every week type of shows
that's not it's almost like the MCU set
itself up to constantly be doing cameos
all the time and now they're annoyed at
people thinking there's gonna be cameos
either way we know that we're getting
lots of cameos in the show as not only
is abomination in one here but we're
also getting Daredevil too let the
cameos commence oh [ __ ] here we go again
now She-Hulk is all about becoming your
best self and that's why we've teamed up
with manscape to bring you their new
performance package 4.0 now inside it
you'll find the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
which has a Cutting Edge ceramic blade
that has Advanced Skin safe technology
you will Marvel at its way from stopping
you getting cut and on top of that it's
also waterproof so you need to Jet out
to Mexico to do some training it's also
got a travel lock function that means it
won't set off when you're on the go it
also has a 4000k LED spotlight that
shines as bright as the Arc Reactor so
if you're shaving at night you can see
your face a lot better or if you're just
shaving in the day also helps as well
I've been using manscape for over a yeah
now it's quick and efficient and it
always gets the job done now after
you've given yourself the perfect
haircut you can also use the crop
preserver ball deodorant spray that will
help your Abomination stay cool it's got
a soothing aloe vera formula and it's
the best in the business when it comes
to keeping you cool and also smelling
great there's also the crop reviver
toner and manscape through in two free
gifts this includes the anti-chafing
boxer briefs that means your Hulk will
never get a rash and the shed travel bag
that will always protect your kit on top
of this if you're wearing sandals you
know in that Mexico trip then make sure
you get the shears 2.0 luxury grooming
kit it's got stainless steel nail
cutters tweezers and grooming scissors
so it's got you covered when it comes to
the rest go to manscape.com and enter
heavy spoilers at the checkout for 20
off and also free shipping That's
manscape.com Heavy spoilers at the
checkout 20 off and free shipping
manscape.com heavy spoilers at the
checkout 20 off free shipping thing you
know you love it see you next time now
we go to Los Angeles news and in keeping
in line with their report from episode 2
we see a PR statement by Titania he says
she's confident her legal team will make
her legal troubles go away I am
expecting to see her popping up in the
series again with this being the subplot
the She-Hulk origin run actually ended
with a battle against Titania in the
Supreme Court another first episode had
something like this I could see it being
also a potential finale now you also get
a picture of Blonsky that's pulled right
out of the Incredible Hulk love how they
have his prison photo too and next we
Jam to the tattle new show it's very
much a play on the gossip news channels
on YouTube and we even pull out to see
some related videos these include the
She-Hulk is not real Theory as well as
how it's a hoax and also the truth about
the so-called She-Hulk lots of
conspiracy theories flying around about
her with people believing she's not real
because of how bad the CGI is oh sorry
it's fine it's sometimes it's just me
being my usual dead self and looking
foreign jokes to Duncan I apologize yet
it's a personality flow now next we get
some social commentary on what the
internet tends to do whenever a female
hero is announced I'm guessing that this
was added in after the backlash when the
show first got teased towards or Marvel
could just be at the point now where
they expect it and I'm just calling it
out in advance I know they really care
because they're probably laughing
straight to the bank but amongst this is
Dom the Bounty Hunter saying so we gotta
have affirmative action with superheroes
hard sells to Steve says no more female
superheroes please Derby don't care says
why are you turning every superhero into
a girl no one asked for that not here to
make friends asks why everything's gonna
be female now and that's weird because
I'm sure I left that comment not him
Neil isn't sorry 32 won someone to find
a reason to cancel She-Hulk and mum's
favorite theorizes whether the hashtag
metoo movement is why all the male
heroes are now gone depends if your hero
was Harvey Weinstein but moving on now
lastly I'm getting so much joke I could
already tell I can already see the
comments being typed now now lastly we
get the common criticism of a guy saying
I have no problem with female Heroes I'm
just saying make your own this is
normally something that said whenever a
character is gender or race swapped and
we even had She-Hulk last week talking
about how all the new Heroes just seem
to be spin-offs kind of funny how you
can also see one that says team he hook
and yeah when are we when I were getting
a bloody Helk I'm bloody raged shut the
[ __ ] up Ryan Airy this whole thing is
just poking fun at general internet
backlash to superhero projects with
people doing blogs from their cars and
also news reports popping up the
conversation with Jefferson Coop feels
like it's partying news reports from
certain wings of the political Spectrum
but one thing that we won't do at the
heavy spoiler show is that we'll never
make fun of you or say that we don't
want you here because of your political
beliefs I'm happy to take money from
everyone and then we see Jen walking in
to take money from Abomination now nice
little detail here that I appreciate is
how history have changed knowing that
he's gonna have to be in the office in
She-Hulk form she's had to get bigger
ones and I'm pretty sure that the one
she has on is a man's suit seems that
way rather than being a woman's and a
nice bit of costume design now turns out
that Dennis is being conned by a light
elf from you Asgard who's been
masquerading as Megan the stallion like
elves are of course the opposite to Dark
Elves who were the main antagonists in
Thor the Dark World you ask God is where
they resettled in tonesberg after the
destruction of their home in Ragnarok
and they're now clearly starting to
integrate more with the humans yeah
we're also introduced to Mallory book in
the comics Mallory was one of the best
lawyers in La who was also notable for
her supermodel looks they called her the
face that never lost the case and she
appeared quite heavily in the Dan slot
run the show seems pretty light-hearted
so I doubt they'll go this route but she
did become an antagonist in the original
work she ended up becoming the
chairperson of a group aptly titled
fourth wall Enterprises which try to
tear She-Hulk down they wanted her to
make their own version that they could
control which could be a possible plot
Point once Jen gets more popular perk
also features heavily in the episode 2
and as we discussed last week he was
kind of a love interest for Jen in the
comics can't see that being the route
that they go in the show and where
they're still having six episodes left
there's a hell of a lot to explore now
at this point Wong teleports in and he
starts to act as a character witness he
says everything Mr blosky told you is
factual I extracted him from the prison
against his own wishes now I kind of
feel like he's lying here as he did talk
to Abomination like the pair had worked
together a lot maybe he'll start
controlling those punches like we'll
practice
seem more like he was training him which
we might get more info on later down the
line Abomination ends up being freed
come the end of the entry and I think
it'll be interesting if we see him in a
future project right before the
Thunderbolts anyway it's two time Utah
so with him walking free it kind of
derails our Theory from last week that
he'd be forced to work with the
Thunderbolts in case you don't know
they're sort of Marvel's answer to the
suicide squad and the group is made up
of supervillains who end up reforming in
order to do good we have a couple of
potential members already such as John
Walker Zemo Elena belova and also
Abomination I am expecting us to see Val
recruiting Abomination and though I
thought it would be from prison she
might just appear at a plot of his land
Blonsky was of course desperate to
become a hero like Captain America and
this could end up being his Redemption
Arc I would love it if this series ended
with a post-credits scene similar to
Black Widow where we watch Valco to him
and that would neatly set things up for
an upcoming bad guy movie Thunderbolts
will release in 2020 before so they'd
really need to start putting things into
production now in order to hit that date
obviously they haven't announced a
director yet so I'm guessing that will
come soon and then we'll go from there
anyway that's um
now one also does this nice little line
this when I'm not raising everyone's
memories not again that's not what I was
thinking then it's highly unethical yeah
it's also a very messy believe me this
of course links back to Spider-Man no
way home which strange did one you
didn't do it mate but maybe this is a
little joke about how everyone forgot so
he doesn't even really know himself he
also talks about sending Abomination to
the mirror in Shadow Dimension The
Mirror Has of course popped up in
several movies at this point and the
shadow dimension is another name for the
dark one this popped up at the end of
Doctor Strange Jana also got a tease in
Multiverse of Madness clear actually
comes from this realm and I'm guessing
that we'll see more of it in Doctor
Strange 3. he agrees to show up at the
hearing and explain it all and hopefully
everything will just blow over now the
subplot follows Dennis and purg going
through the former's case turns out that
he bought the elf a midsize sedan which
always makes me think about the movie
old and the rapper in that could have
said in episode 1 yet that they were
went to the beach that makes you go
green hey oh you suck anyway on his
laptop we see the YouTube parody you
screen get the QR code and also see a
related video talking about how a pony
imposter thinks it's a stallion there's
also a video for malcolo Tay which
translates to In Spite of you which I
have no idea what this is a reference to
and you guys are smarter than me so you
probably know so drop drop it in the
comments below now until that we also
have the Iron Man 3's honest review
video which links back to the laptop
Easter egg last week at this point in
the video we see the elf transforming
back and this sets up the introduction
for them to come in pretending to be
Dennis pug is alerted by the real Dennis
and we can hear that he drives a cyber
truck
you there any Jaws on the floor because
I drive a cyber truck security they're
made by Tesla and yeah obviously the
writers are like guy drives a Tesla he's
a douchebag but you know what I I think
the cars are all right so maybe it's
saying something about me and that's why
I [ __ ] hate Marvel these days [ __ ] I
hate them anyway it's time for the best
part of the show Jared's Easter eggs
[Music]
so at the damage control prison we see
lines of reporters waiting to report on
the results of the abomination's trial
now during this Jen is actually asked by
a reporter whether or not she was
actually rejected from The Avengers and
then a reporter from this news then
reports on it immediately now this shows
how the news about Jen or her She-Hulk
Persona is spiraling out of control but
also ties back to the Dan slot run of
comics in that Jen lived in The Avengers
Mansion but then was eventually kicked
out because of all of her partying now
in the credits we see an Easter egg of
Jen picking up a cabinet while her mom
vacuumed underneath and this is pulled
directly from that book but instead of
her mom it's Jarvis in the prison we see
blonde ski soulmates and they're all
wearing these white floral dresses
evoking images similar to that of the
cult from mid-summer now obviously
everyone knows that white dresses are a
symbolism for marriage so the
Abomination has seven different
soulmates while in prison and you can't
even get a date
you suck
what the hell Jared mate I'm not having
that like guys if you're watching if
this video gets 50 000 likes I'll
publicly fire Jared on a live stream
make sure that like button gets hit
because I know he's a piece of crap now
blonsky's trial might even be a slight
nod to the trial of the Incredible Hulk
that's already been referenced slightly
in the first episode when we had the
courtroom fight it's similar to that
made for TV movie and at this point we
get more character Witnesses on screen
we can catch their names and a Google
searched each one of them Amy chance is
actually the name of a Marvel supervisor
according to LinkedIn and hopefully
everyone starts adding hair right now
I'm sure sure she'll love that now cowet
is also the name of a costume designer
that works in the company anyway Wong
finally arrives and we catch what looks
like a couching camitage mirroring this
trial rooner's defense tries to go for
diplomatic immunity naruna also ends up
aiming Thor's speech about Asgard at the
end of Ragnarok Asgard is not a place it
is a people Star Wars inspirational
speeches are not admissible in court now
there's a bit of a mistake there and you
know people always point out my mistakes
so I relish whenever I can do it it was
actually Odin who said it and also
Heimdall as good as another place never
was as God is not a place
it's a people Kevin feige you're a chump
see a chump now Ruiner in the comics is
actually the name of one of the
Valkyries that served Asgard I don't
think that's the case here but it could
be a link to the Donnie Kate's run now
after a bit of a comedy Switcheroo
Dennis starts coming out on top I think
he might end up popping up again in
future episodes as he does pull from the
comics Dennis Bakowski was also a DA in
the source material that constantly
tried to outdo Jen he ended up
Prosecuting Lou Moncton who had been
framed by Nicholas Trask and after gen
beat him he kept trying to outdo her now
mirroring this win we get one with
abomination after Wong reveals that he
offered him Asylum at komitage but that
he wanted to return to serve out his
sentence Asylum was also given to Rin
Troy in Multiverse of Madness and
according to the deleted scene leaks he
was meant to be shown to arrive there in
order to seek out a home after being
questioned on it Blonsky decides to show
that he's in control of the Beast Within
and he transforms they do cut around
this and him turning back to save money
on the CGI budget which is weird as I'm
sure they had more of it in the trailer
maybe they just didn't have time to
finish it off there's been a number of
VFX workers recently saying they've been
overworked by the studio and have to get
things out quicker than a heavy spoilers
video so who knows what's really going
on there also at this weird comment on
the first video saying that if you
complain about the CGI it just means you
hate women
does it though really everyone panics
and they need to come up with a way that
it can be controlled as they leave we
also get this nice little line is there
any truth to the rumors you got your
powers from a mafia had gone wrong this
calls back to the comics and in those
she was shot by a gang of mobsters Bruce
ended up having to give her a blood
transfusion in order to save her life
and when the mob returned to finish the
job she ended up changing it to She-Hulk
back at the bar Jen talks about how
she's being lumped in with a
monster-like Abomination we also get the
theory that she's having a baby with a
character and look look at that look at
that cute little Obama baby move over
baby Vision you're dead to me and after
talking with pug Jen drops what is
probably my second favorite wall break
in the whole show you're gonna need that
connecting the A and B story nice now I
can't actually think of a time outside
the stuff with sword and the main plot
point in one division then MCU show
actually connected the A and B storyline
so well done there guys now Bo gets it I
swear on the earth that Dennis is
additional and we get more Mega in the
stallion in what becomes the biggest MCU
Cameo since Elon Musk popped up in Iron
Man 2. connecting the Elon Musk and
cyber truck jog there nice also before
you start I quite I did say I quite
liked them yeah I didn't say I worshiped
the ground that the guy walked on before
you start because I know what you're
like but you put your keyboard down now
in a great time from this to the
Abomination plot Jen gets the idea from
Dennis to inhibit Emil's Powers he's
fitted with an inhibited device similar
to Bruce and this means that he'll stay
in human form like he did guessing that
this will get smashed up too so that he
can be in the Thunderbolts and I swear
if this doesn't happen then I've wasted
about 10 minutes across every video
talking about nonsense now when we join
Emil we can actually see one of his
tattoos under his sleeve this also
popped up in the Incredible Hulk as well
but rather than being a character Design
This actually belongs to Tim Roth who
has it in real life this is a tribal
armband and Rother said in interviews at
each one of his tattoos has a
significant meaning for him whilst I
couldn't find an example of him saying
exactly what this one means it tends to
signify the death or birth of a loved
one now She-Hulk follows Nikki and
Emil's advice and decides to tackle a
news head-on and give an interview with
them in order to control a narrative she
explains her name origins and it goes
pretty well that night though she's
attacked by The Wrecking Crew who all
have mystical weapons these villains
actually pull from the comics and we
know from the trailers that they'll be
showing up again as for their origin
story they were born when their leader
wrecker and three others grabbed an
enchanted crowbar just as a belt of
lightning struck it this was also held
by Thunderball bulldozer and pile driver
this granted them all mystical abilities
and in the comics they've been
antagonists of Thor now we learned that
they actually robbed in Asgardian
construction worker and this might even
tine with the light elf though we don't
get any further details on it though
they get their asses handed to them they
do tease that they're working for
someone else now there is the potential
that this could be the roxon corporation
which would tie back to the theories on
the first episode though we never
learned who Holloway was acting in
defensive in the first episode Ryan Airy
bloody ryanairy he theorized that it
might have been for Roxanne however
think they might actually be under the
villain in the hood who we know is going
to be popping up in ironheart in the
comics the gang actually worked for him
at one point and his criminal Empire
would be the kinds of people that would
go after her blood however this Blood
may also tine with Titania this was
carried out by Dr Doom during the first
events of Secret Wars and it could tie
in with that I did think Titania got
took out too easily and she has been
laced throughout the episode since
namely in the news reports we haven't
really got a main antagonist here yet so
it would make sense to build up someone
Jen slightly through Titania the comics
also ended with a big fight with Heron
Court so this would tie things all
together and to me be the most likely
option now the credit song plays upon
this idea of getting her blood and we
hear the song seize the power by yanaka
this is lines about how the power is
yours for the taking linking back to the
wrecking crew trying to grab it from her
you also see elements of the show now in
credit form such as Emil's wives as they
scream whilst he's taken out the cube
there's also Nikki holding up some books
and Dennis and the light elves date the
post-credits scene and ends with Megan
hiring She-Hulk and the pairs start
twerking now as with my thoughts on this
episode I think this was probably the
one I enjoyed the most out of the three
[Music]
yes I finally said I actually liked one
of them now I know the Tim Roth stuff
has the Abomination a bit but I like the
comedic side of it and it's always good
to see Wong in an episode I think that
this will probably also be the format
that the show goes in from now for
example the first episode was the origin
stuff the second was about her getting a
job and her first client whereas this
will probably now be the procedural
style that the Shelf follows so I think
whether you'll like the series or not
will be very dependent on how you feel
about this episode I think it's been
okay I know I probably was too hard on
it in my first two videos but to be fair
I was coming off the back of the Better
Call Saul finale that's one of the best
lawyer shows of all time and I think in
general when you compare the MCU Disney
plus stuff other shows are at the moment
they fall a bit short writing wise in
the last two months the boys stranger
things Westworld Blackbird Sandman House
of the dragon and Umbrella Academy have
all released which I feel had episodes
that were real standouts I think these
episodes so far kind of throw away story
wise but they're really elevated by the
performances Tatiana does a brilliant
job week to week and having this Wong
and Abomination heavy episode made it my
favorite so far did I sound like I was
still crapping on the show a bit there
yeah probably I'm just trying to explain
why it's not completely blowing me away
because I'm probably comparing it to
other things that have come out recently
so again probably being too hard on it
but I'm just trying to explain why it
feels like another Disney Plus show
rather than being the must-see TV that
the other shows are brought apart anyway
I'd love to hear your thoughts I'm sure
sure get taller much of an idiot I am
again so yeah make sure you drop them in
the comments below I love love reading
that will make me feel really good about
myself now we are already in competition
right now now and giving away three
copies of top gun Maverick on the 15th
of September all you have to do to be
when the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you message me on Twitter at
heavy spoilers you answer me wants to
watch then make sure you check out our
brighten up House of the Dragon which
will be linked on screen right now
there's lots to talk about and whether
you're a newcomer to the books or you've
read them page to page 700 times like I
have just that one chapter then uh yeah
definitely go head over there right
after this by the way thanks for singing
through the video I've been Paul I'll
see you in the next one take care peace